whatever the [ __ ] is going down you're
alive [ __ ] what's happening my little
jewish brother
you bad [ __ ] you what are you
gonna do you don't miss this it's monday
june 2nd i'm ready to stab a
[ __ ] there's so much to tell
where do we start today
we can start with the live podcast which
was sensational
ari sophia always bringing it taking it
to the hoop
how to get up because he was taking a
long distance call from china yeah who
speaks to chinese people on a wednesday
night
thursday san diego [ __ ] phenomena i'm
out of driving shapely
oh i'm definitely out of driving you're
not in a driving shape listen man you
know for years i drove a lot i drove to
all these gigs
now you fly in your wind in your car you
[ __ ] don't have it no more i bought
that car in january i got 3 000 miles
i used to put 3 000 miles a week on a
[ __ ] car leak jesus you know a week
you know i'm exaggerating but you know
what i'm saying okay but i feel like
you're not telling the whole story what
[ __ ] story we got high and we drove
down man that was uh you said get there
at like 3 45 4 o'clock somewhere around
there we get there and you start wearing
errands i'm like where is he going he's
going to atm okay maybe he wants to pay
tip the bartender and i'm like oh [ __ ]
no we're going to the weed store went to
the weed store which a lot of them are
closing around the area we're getting uh
you got a stock up it's uh yeah you got
to stock up but but i've been going
listen noah organic has been one of my
favorites since day one i've had some
great weed stores i had the one in
hollywood kushmart
with my main man me and ralph used to go
up there and get the mats og
and then i moved to the valley i can't
drive to [ __ ] hollywood every day so
i got divine wellness i had
the other no-hold one on um lancashire
that moved
but divine wellness closed down divine
wellness had some great edibles but no
organic has always been in the run they
they were and i like tony i like the
whole staff that the mexican chick
uh the little mexican kid i like the
owner j i mean they're just good people
if you go to that place they got all the
name brands we talk about you know they
got auntie dolores they got chibachu
they've got the other new ones the only
ones they don't have is the uh
the chocolate bars i get bang no no no
the other ones are curb whatever the
[ __ ] they are oh but uh
uh
what do you call that the strongest
edible and no organic is these [ __ ]
200 milligram cookies and how
they're ugly as [ __ ] how much did you
tell me they were like don't worry about
it you're like totally he gave it to me
like it's 10 milligrams
you go like a a bakery and they have
that big chinese cookie or the big
cookie with the chocolate the black and
white
the black and white cookie it's like
that it's a big [ __ ] cookie
so you break that [ __ ] in half
i'll tell you what
you will see stars i guarantee you you
will see stars now they have one in the
top shelf that's 200 and they have one
in the bot in the middle shelf that
they're a hundred but on the second
shelf they also have fudge squares
okay on the third square they have sodas
they have thc sodas and they have auntie
dolores in the mix
let me tell you something i love auntie
dolores i love chibo chew we've
discussed them
nothing will rock your world like this
200 milligram cookie
nothing lee has anything rocked your
world that hard
the only thing that got close was when i
had the one and a half green hornets but
this was one thing
and i just and the thing that got me
was it took a while to get down there
and
you you you started getting high because
then after you took the half like 30
minutes later you just downed a whole
jubitee oh i just ate a chiba chew on
top but like a [ __ ] soldier was
sitting in traffic yeah but that's the
thing someone i forget who it was i
think maybe it was wrecked but we were
talking about how when you were driving
you don't really see it you can't really
sit still
can you you would start opening the
windows a little bit do the ac a little
bit but then you started getting high
so we were doing about 90 down the
highway with all four windows down wide
open
going a thousand and i'm freezing but i
can't look and then we stopped and got
snacks so we thought we were close
because for whatever whatever reason we
stopped looking at the gps we went off
by what the promoter said
um what's your name she was mommy
she's very nice um
but you got mints
and you ate like a quarter of the pack
at once i was but i couldn't even
i couldn't let me
something and i couldn't look at you
we were so [ __ ] stoned by that point
and the chibachu was kicking in
so now we gotta drive but now it's no
more interstate freeway it's winds and
valleys like what do you call those
winding roads yeah we're on the indian
reservation there's an indian
reservation with one road going that way
and one coming this way it's a two-laner
it's a two-rotor as my friend fernie
basico yeah it felt like east coast
yeah it did feel like the east coast
we're driving and i'm getting sicker and
sick i get [ __ ] car sick my
reputation you know since i was a kid i
got [ __ ] cars sick so now i'm getting
carsick
and i gotta pull over with 20 minutes
and we made a left i made a left
somewhere that took us up this [ __ ]
hill of death
and i'm like lee i don't see no lights
it kept getting darker the gps wasn't
working he was tom to go [ __ ] himself
we finally called it back she goes turn
around we made a u-turn and that one
before i made that u-turn i had to pull
over yeah that was hard and then i
looked like this was the weird thing i
didn't tell lee so i'm getting anxiety
i'm sweating perfuciously i'm getting
sick
i get out of the [ __ ] car i closed
the door yeah i'm just breathing
i looked to the side of the road and
somebody died there they got flowers
there and [ __ ] oh no and indian arrows
and [ __ ]
so now i gotta sit there and go and
that's what i look there go we you know
we're going to die
no i might tell you we're going to die i
thought you got another car out of the
car to call monique i thought you got
out of the car to do that oh my god i
thought i'd get [ __ ] air i didn't
want to call we're going to call money i
could have called her in the car right
direct without even picking up the
[ __ ] phone
i pulled over like breathe and get my
head right and [ __ ]
oh and then we went and then we went to
the one side of the casino that didn't
have valet and i was like this is never
going to end
oh but they stopped there then we had to
get around but i had to do like by that
point
i was doing eight miles an hour because
i couldn't even drive no more guys
that's how classic i was
i couldn't even [ __ ] drive anymore i
was getting so goddamn car sick
so i pulled over the valet cam we walked
in the air conditioner helped we drank
so even in that little green room yeah i
was about to puke
yeah how was it remember i said to you
give me the garbage can
and it had no [ __ ] garbage lining in
it and i'm like i'm i'm gonna puke in a
no [ __ ] garden and then you see the
guy who came in moved it and i was like
don't move that but it was too high to
tell him oh my god
but then about 10 minutes before i got
on stage with the water and just
standing up and we weren't in the
groomer for that long i felt like we
were in the room for like six minutes
and then you went on stage for an hour
like how was he doing it
and then i tried to wait in the green
room for as long as possible because
when you left you were right on stage
and i didn't wanna like the people were
crazy they started cheering when we got
there there was some crazy people so i
didn't want just to drive down that
[ __ ] road you got to be crazy oh yeah
i wanted to get i wanted your show to
like be going on for as long as possible
before i tried to sneak out and it
didn't really work but then luckily they
brought the chicken and you kept doing
like five-minute checkups tell me like
we have the chicken are you doing okay
yeah i couldn't even answer you i was
just like
i don't know how we made it home but i
know we made it home in two hours oh
yeah i i was on an hour on the way home
i was doing okay and i introduced you to
a puerto rican italian sandwich at
7-eleven
yeah that was actually pretty good i
told you but this is what you do with
the 7-eleven italians
listen we live in california before you
start [ __ ] judging so few people
going joey you didn't just say that yes
i did [ __ ] say that because where do
you get an italian sandwich around here
i mean a real italian sandwich like you
grew up with on the east coast you don't
so what you got to do is dope them up
that's what i live off dope [ __ ] up
sometimes pizza i'm done with so you got
to dope it up so you got to get mama
celeste and dope it up i got to go to
the one place and to hunger get the pie
bring it home
re-dope it up and put it back on the
[ __ ] level it's brilliant i've done
it a couple of times it's delicious i'll
make you [ __ ] slice that what do you
put on it mozzarella i put [ __ ] some
peppers on it i put some real you know
you just re-dope it up you put some
olive oil on the [ __ ] custard crust
again
these mothers savages don't [ __ ] know
these gentiles don't know how to [ __ ]
cook you look at an italian sandwich
here it tastes like [ __ ]
it tastes like [ __ ] an italian sandwich
is ham
kappa cool whatever the [ __ ] prosciutto
or some [ __ ]
maybe some mortadella some provolone
some [ __ ] lettuce
some pepperoncinis some sweet peppers
vinegar oil salt and pepper and [ __ ]
oregano that's an italian sandwich i
hope that's as close as i know
ham salami
genoa you know ham genoa
mortadelle i don't even think the
prosciutto is in there i don't even
think the prosciutto you don't need it
the cup of cool will do great with the
[ __ ] pres uh whatever you know
listen anyway 711 got a sandwich like a
pepperoni salami provolone cheese and
the bread ain't bad what you do is you
take that [ __ ] home you rebake
it like an old school steward sandwiches
if you remember steward sandwiches that
means you're old school and you were an
old school [ __ ] coke head you went
into a bar and they had like this little
oven and you tell them what you want and
they took a sandwich out and it was in a
baggie and they put it in the oven with
the baggie and it was like popcorn to
where it is today it would go pop and
then the [ __ ] they would open the bag
and the steam would come out and your
sandwich wasn't that bad
me and my [ __ ] gorilla buddies ate a
thousand of those at joan mary's and
bars all over the east coast from the
bronx to [ __ ] connecticut when i
wished to go up there and do highlight
stewart sandwiches were all over the
east coast that's where i got the idea
from you take that [ __ ] sandwich home
you put it in the oven you rebake a
little bit get the heart the bread to
get hard and crispy burn that
[ __ ] yeah it comes out you shave
some lettuce shave it not just put like
[ __ ] adam's leaf
you shave some lettuce you put some
vinegar on that [ __ ] some
pepperoncinis yeah you were telling me
to do this at 2 a.m in a 7-eleven
parking lot i'm like i can't i'm not
going to do any of that right now i
remember the two guys that came up to me
and said you look like the guy from the
longest shot on my mom i hear that all
the time yeah they walked away and there
was a black guy in the car and when they
say that he's like i know who you are
you're joey diaz but these two [ __ ]
dudes are like me and you're like you're
like you got it he's like i don't know
those dudes
he said something at the end he's like
i'll let those dudes not know or
something or a [ __ ] craziness no we
had a good night that was a good [ __ ]
i had a very peaceful weekend i'll tell
you what i did this week and i pulled
the lead
what do you i didn't watch sports though
i watched i caught up on some movies
nice and you feel relaxed right you feel
nice
yeah listen man i learned a big when i
used to work at the comedy store like
paul mooney was there a lot and i asked
paul
paul when you look in the right comedy
what do you do when you're stuck and he
goes go get entertained
and i got entertained the only i watched
21 grams okay an old movie
i watched two movies back to back which
is very rare for me i sat there and
watched 21 grams and whatever was on
before that which is very good and i
watched the captain phillips again
oh
and you were so excited when you were
watching that yeah yeah yeah the [ __ ]
four days in the raft
with [ __ ] four black dudes when they
came out there are you okay am i okay
i've been in a [ __ ] dinghy with four
[ __ ] somalians and no water and no
soap what do you think i [ __ ]
remember he was he was great tom hanks
and that i was eating it and i watched
uh uh what else i just hung out with the
family
i worked out i went to friday night jiu
jitsu you know i had a good time i got
beat up
saturday i did nothing just a family
thing and uh
watched a little bit of ufc but didn't
really get caught up in it and then
sunday i did the same yes that really
didn't do [ __ ] yeah and i felt really
bad about it i couldn't shake something
like they weren't feeling good i wasn't
feeling good the best thing i did yes i
did that podcast with steve simone
oh yeah i had a really good time with
steve simone we taped it over there at
uh marie etc we met at nine in the
morning there was not a [ __ ] soul
there
and we just sat there and talked [ __ ] a
lot of noise a lot of background noise
though a little bit mike don't really
catch up catch it so you're fine but
beside that that was it it's real you
know i'm back in salt lake city this
week and the week after that i've been
long
so i didn't really [ __ ] want to do
much lee just really wasn't into
going crazy this weekend i don't know
why you know no i i mean i agree and i
have to actually thank you we didn't
i think you told me oh it's on the way
down to san diego you told me what's
that well then
what what i ended up doing for paula
well we were talking about just thinking
about how
you know paula goes to law school but
you brought it up out of nowhere like
the way i remember it was we were just
sitting there and then he was like he
looked at me like when does paula start
her job so you were thinking about it by
yourself
yeah you know uh
listen man the church of what's
happening now is basically i got a whole
[ __ ] to tell you the church what's
happening now is basically about
your growth that's what it's become how
people see you've grown if you listen to
episode two oh god
i don't even want to
you wouldn't even take a fart to the
face in episode 100 and now you're at
least [ __ ] i'll take it and uh it's
also about making somebody's day you
know i don't want this to be i don't
ever want to be put on the pressure this
has to be [ __ ] funny
because if that's the impact you're not
going to be [ __ ] funny every goddamn
day but that's all i could give you i
could give you making your day by at one
point of the [ __ ] podcast
with an idea or something
and
watching lee's growth i'm a broke oh man
i got nothing going on
uh and that's what the show's about me
and lee were driving to san diego we're
[ __ ] stoned this [ __ ] we blast music
we heard every genre of [ __ ] lee
knows i love it but it was so weird i
know we're getting off track a little
bit but you don't listen to the music i
think you would
like you listen to rock but you're into
like
more of ballads like you don't like the
whole you know you kind of skipped over
the hard stuff and you like it really
really singing like i was kind of i was
like yeah i was expecting hard stuff and
you were like the ones that they would
get into and sing i was like oh this is
what he likes this is yeah i didn't like
i don't like that heavy heavy
[ __ ] kill your uncle all that [ __ ]
music i really don't i like a lot of
you know tom petty was great on the
right down we listened to she's a woman
in love yeah just these songs that you
don't put up you don't put on by
yourself
sometimes the radio reminds you how good
music is i'm very happy i have serious
radio and i'm very happy to have ozzie's
blowing you on i get to listen to jim
florentine and we listen to norton on
the way down that lane that night and uh
the the best [ __ ] station on there is
this hip-hop station where they just run
away
yums
that's all i could call them they're not
even black people anymore they're not
even black they started out being black
they passed the [ __ ] one stage
now they just hold a hardcore
gangster yarms and i love it i put it on
when i'm in the wife in the car with my
wife i put it on when i'm gonna call it
myself i don't know what the station is
it's five or six stations after
uh aussies boneyard that way
and it's old school it's not even
old-school hip-hop it's just i don't
even know what it is
they had fat joe on there one day i was
[ __ ] dying listening to what they
were saying
if you're easily offended do not listen
to this station
it's just black guys [ __ ] dropping it
dropping and she's a whole [ __ ] that
[ __ ] it was the weak solange hit jay-z
yeah i never heard nothing like that i
thought my podcast our podcast was bad
nothing they were calling her a [ __ ]
everything that dirty [ __ ]
no korea having [ __ ] i mean just
horrid things but anyway i love that i
love all that [ __ ] yeah you know lee i
listen to everything
uh i got the chance this weekend i
called you i don't uh you don't want to
pay the extra seven dollars
i watched something i never thought i'd
watch i watched the hbo uh
rock and roll hall of fame inductions i
didn't watch all of it
i watched bits and pieces of it but i
turned it on as bruce springsteen was on
okay with the e street band he was
inducting the e street band
and it made me fall in love with bruce
springsteen what it was beautiful
he just [ __ ] dropped it and then i
saw the nirvana one
they inducted nirvana god damn they
weren't in there yet no the guy from rem
brought them up and defined lightning in
a bottle
and then i saw uh dave grohl's speech
holy [ __ ]
but one thing dave grohl
nirvana
bruce springsteen especially
was
their love of music they knew all let me
tell you some kid rock is a [ __ ]
knucklehead
but you ain't gonna beat quit uh kid
rock on jeopardy about music
he knows everything
when they get to that level of musician
you've listened to everything you've
you've picked up a little something from
everything
you know it's really weird that it was
the first time i picked up a heavy-duty
correlation you know people might think
joey's funny or people might not think
i'm funny either way it doesn't matter
but you see who your influences are
and with me it wasn't as much as the
comedians as the people i hung around
with
and there's got to be i have maybe 10
people that i hung around with that
influenced me and nobody will ever know
or hear of and then i mix it in with
dice clay and rodney and and bill hicks
and
a little bit of kennison and i become
something you know when you're a
musician that's the same [ __ ] thing
it's the same [ __ ] thing
you know uh you go to work my wife said
that the reason why she really quit her
job this year wasn't because of the baby
and wasn't because she wanted to help me
with the t-shirts it was because they
gave her a 1.7 percent raise of the job
the girl that she worked with got like a
1.2
but my wife does accounting and she
realized that all the people in these
other divisions that the divisions were
weaker were getting 12 percent
uh
percentage raises
[ __ ] that's what really hurt my wife and
man my wife don't yell but when i see
her yell in the kitchen with the baby in
the room i know there's a problem and
when she was breaking this down to me
last week i realized what happens to us
when we become artist i hate saying that
word when one day we say you know what
[ __ ] society
[ __ ] society you you uh you're not
[ __ ] me anymore i'm putting my life
in and i'm getting up early i don't
steal from you i don't even take an
extra sugar when my [ __ ] coffee i get
there at [ __ ] a half hour early and i
leave a half hour later and you give me
1.7 raise but the [ __ ] guy who comes
in late and is drinking all the time and
whatever he gets 12 whatever right
that's what happens to people one day
it's amazing how quick for some people
it happens when you're 19 like it
happened for me and for some people it
happens when you're 40 but it's never
too late that's when you go you know
what i've been putting all this effort
into somebody else's [ __ ] [ __ ] it i'm
going to do this for myself now right
and i'm going to do this and this is
what i'm going to make my own hours and
i don't want to ever work full time
again i don't that's where you get your
strength i saw my wife snappy this week
oh it happens and
for me
i've told you my parents are
they weren't never against it but they
they were always nervous for me my mom
finally got on board yesterday she
called me and she was because i'm moving
we're talking and she's like so do you
think because the shows are starting
right around now she's like so are you
thinking about getting a new job i was
like no not really i'm i'm making less
but maybe i've figured it out i'm making
enough money survived she like
congratulations she like was because i
see what she's going through now
like towards the end of her career and
just the [ __ ] of the [ __ ] they put her
through
and it's uh
i'm i was talking to paula i'm so much
i'm making less money but i'm so much
happier like not going over the 405
every day twice a day jesus christ so
it's just
it's scary but people people start
getting like understanding what you're
talking about
and it's and the the worst part is
is it's not that other people who get a
bigger raise but it's like
i the boss who doesn't come in until 12
and leaves early
and and he he he talked you see in the
new in the newsletter that he got a a 26
bonus because corporate was happy it's
like that that's the stuff that really
pissed me off it's like and it's like
you guys are doing all the hard work and
somebody else has to smile
and now you know and like i tell people
all the time with me it i was 19 and i
was like why am i doing this
i could be doing this i really i used to
get furious like i'm doing this for 10
bucks an hour i can make 10 bucks an
hour with one drug deal or kicking one
window in
but that's not what i really wanted to
do i just wanted to [ __ ] do something
that i could work for myself yeah like
and that's why i think i basically got
into comedy i mean that's basic that was
the easiest business i could enter
without having a ukulele or a [ __ ]
guitar or a piano or a monkey you know
that was the easiest [ __ ] thing i
could get into but i see
it's a weird day when that happens to
you
like for me the day at snap is the day i
couldn't make my credit card payment
like i thought my credit
credit card would be ruined like i was i
was raised on paying your bills yeah my
credit would be ruined i was shot as an
american today i couldn't make my
[ __ ] credit card payment you know i
was shocked
as an american the day that
i realized what life was after college i
realized that the day you graduate
college you're done
you're done you're done you have a
realization you're going to these firms
you know here you've got your college
you're paying back your loans and one
day while you're writing that check to
pay back your loans you go wow this is
basically it
yeah this is it so you're you're even
paying them back forever regardless yeah
you're like this is it i'm
i'm gonna in ten years i'm gonna be the
guy that's ahead of me
and then one day when i'm 65 i retire
and they give me a gold [ __ ] watch
and on the weekends i mow the lawn i
take the kids to [ __ ] church and i go
to denny's and eat that's it this is it
this is all i'm gonna do some people say
yeah this is what i'm gonna do and some
people say [ __ ] it i'm going to figure
something else out i want to go to
ireland
i want to go to thailand and get my dick
lick i want to paint house you know
whatever it's so weird how way your
inside comes out and overwhelms your
beliefs that's what basically comes down
to and you have to commit you have to
[ __ ] put everything you can i don't
work 40 hours a week i work 80 hours a
week i talked to my brother mike runner
yesterday he's called the podcast he
just got a new job he's 52 he's working
70 hours a week he worked 19 hours on
friday
as a general manager of a store he's on
salary yeah he's making you know 80 90
grand a year but on a [ __ ] friday
he's got to put in 19 [ __ ] hours at
52. jesus you know can you imagine doing
construction work at 52 or my buddy
timmy who drives a truck i hope he's out
of the hospital i know he was home
resting he put the wrong pad on his back
he tells me i said he has to break down
pallets every day and [ __ ] like that
jesus you know you fed your family they
put us into a bad position so now we
have to do something we don't want to do
and then we realize why we're not
[ __ ] happy yeah
and i i want to
be an advocate for this
okay and i never did it because i always
felt like you should have a job if
you're if it
for people who are my age 25 let's say
you work right out of college for a few
years
take unemployment for a little bit if
you're unhappy
that you put you pay into it every week
look at your check you pay into it i
never took it and it it saved me at the
beginning of this now i'm doing okay but
it saved me at the beginning and it's
just sitting there
you're going to pay taxes into it and
you pay taxes for what they give you
so if if you worked for
i worked for like four years or so three
years and i think i have a year of
benefits something like that
so [ __ ] use it i mean you're paying
taxes into it you know i was such a
jerk-off when i was younger when i got
fired from mass back century when i was
going to high school and i got sick and
they fired me collecting unemployment
because i got fired they told me but
then afterward i always thought that why
would i collect unemployment if i go out
and steal
there's an american that could use it
seriously maybe he's got a disability
that he can't get a job i really thought
this way and i never touched it again it
was ari shafir
five years ago who who said to me you
don't collect unemployment
i'm like no he goes all the movies you
do you don't
you're not like
leave unemployment
go get your money you know whenever you
shoot a commercial the next day you're
eligible for unemployment like the
[ __ ] next day you gotta call in and
go hey guess what yeah i'm ready for you
so that's what got me on and i collected
it for years with no shame and you're
right it is your [ __ ] money you know
right and it loosens you up a little bit
gives you a time to think and strategize
because if they're gonna see what you're
[ __ ] next because they tax people
like us thirty percent the people who
can who can do millions of dollars like
like mitt romney who paid 17
if they're gonna tax us thirty percent
i'm gonna take the part that they say i
can take
so it's
it's just uh
yeah that i mean people don't do it and
it's it's i
that could be your start for a new thing
it was for me you know it's funny how
all this came about into diving into
what you're gonna do
when you dive into your belief you have
to dive into your belief you know if
you're gonna be a musician you know
to [ __ ] dave grove i think that's his
name the drama from nirvana and now he's
got the foo fighters i know it's grow
but he was talking about sitting in the
back of a van eating
day old pizza [ __ ] listening to
you know little richard and something
like that you'd never think that the guy
from nirvana will listen to little
richard
but you have to you have to understand
you show me a musician or comic that
doesn't know the history of this [ __ ]
thing
or hasn't have you ever had a
conversation with mike tyson
no neither have i yet
but have you ever seen that have you
ever seen him get interviewed
no
great he knows everything about boxing
he'll talk to you about boxes in the 40s
boxes in the 30s he'll go back to bed
knuckle boxing he'll go back to the
history of [ __ ] two cavemen you know
choking each other he knows everything
about it
and that's what i don't understand like
when you dive yourself into yourself and
you dive yourself into what you believe
in whether it's boxing personal training
comedy drawing whatever you have to know
everything about anything and when i
heard bruce springsteen speech
it was [ __ ] beautiful especially
talked about clarence clemens and and uh
the guy from the sopranos you know i
don't know what the the guy who played
the [ __ ] concierge whatever his name
was you know i wasn't never a big bruce
springsteen fan i don't know much about
him you know when i was growing up in
jersey i got beat up with them so it
kind of got it was a turn off mm-hmm and
i liked a few songs on some of the
albums but as i grew older i appreciated
them the other night they came full
[ __ ] circle i really dug it because i
understood his struggle
you know i understood the struggle as a
man and to get somewhere and then you
reach it you know it's not just
once you [ __ ] make it as a musician
that's when it really gets hard because
now you got to follow up all that [ __ ]
yeah
him and that guitar player knew each
other for 50 [ __ ] years
him in that one miami steve van zandt
whatever his [ __ ] name is you know
and it's amazing how
this is what i do this is what i do i
have to be really good at all the facets
of it you know uh in two weeks i'm gonna
be on marin i acted on that you know
when we come to the podcast i have to be
good at doing the podcast on thursday
nights when i get on stage and i can't
be good every night at this [ __ ] but i
have to dive myself into this you know i
have to dive myself into this [ __ ] and
it's amazing if you're gonna
when when i finally realized when that
through uh whatever came to me like that
happened to my wife at 44 it came to my
wife and she was [ __ ] yelling in the
kitchen she's like why should i [ __ ]
you know
it's it's amazing when it when it hit me
i was very sad
like i thought the american way was the
american way you went to college you got
a job you joined the country club you
hit golf balls young out with [ __ ]
gentiles but it sucks
it sucks it's a [ __ ] struggle and
then at the end you [ __ ] die and you
count your pennies from your retirement
right and you you [ __ ] die you might
as well live a [ __ ] little or
put that belief that you're going to put
into jcpenney or whatever corporation
whatever the accompanying up in your
brother-in-law's plumbing company
whatever and put it into yourself you
know put the effort into yourself and
yeah you're going joey that's easy for
you to say you know go hey listen man if
you believe in yourself you've got a
small loan
if you believe in what you're selling
you'll figure it the [ __ ] out mm-hmm we
all do we just sometimes think we got to
get oh we're going to get an sba loan
from that i don't know if they're giving
out that many loans you know what i'm
saying so whatever you choose on you got
to get a job to finance it yourself or
sell a kilo a blow
or at least
like when i when i was doing this and tv
i saved i i didn't like i'm not driving
around in a bmw i could have
put i could have spent the money that i
was making from both places but i saved
like almost every penny i made from the
podcast and it it like if you're gonna
be working at least save it so that in a
year or two you could
spend a little bit of time and working
on goals you know i
i was always never a big saver you know
because i was like [ __ ] i'ma save money
for one please and it's weird how
uh
you have to
you know uh
my wife for example
one day we're going through [ __ ] and my
wife goes do you see what i have saved
for from my job and i looked and i
couldn't [ __ ] believe it
and i go i'm gonna take you to save that
you know she goes oh it took me six
years you know
taking a little percentage of my check
every week it's amazing yeah i wish i
had that fortitude i wish i had the in
the way she said she goes i just get it
taken out of my check i don't even see
it i don't have to touch it oh yeah i
didn't i never got to that level but yes
that's what you got to do
i mean that the way you talk about how
you like you rob a gas station have
three grand and be gone in four days
it freaks me out i can't i've never even
really thought about it because i can't
imagine that you didn't put a thousand
away or
it is uh that's part of the [ __ ]
thrill
that was part of the high the high was
in three days i would go to the front
desk of the hotel where i was staying
pay for five days
and go [ __ ] it friday at 12 o'clock is d
day
you know what [ __ ] it let's do saturday
at 12 o'clock it's d day i gotta figure
it out by saturday
and it would force me
to be a savage
i could not lay my more you know it's
it's funny i was telling my wife last
night about george
george is starting uh framing business
with his sister
my friend george and i said you know
terry
i've uh
when people pay me cash sometimes
i take the top hundred off
and i save it
okay right and i save it and then every
couple weeks i put it away in the bank
and it's not it doesn't even go on my
account
and the funny thing is i like my wife i
put away a couple hundred in there in
the last two years
and my buddy george
is uh
is opening up a framing company with his
sister
and
i seen what he's been doing lately you
know george really had to pick it up
george divorced his wife he has a
different girlfriend he lives with in
grandma's apartment and she gets a low
rent so he picks up the rent and he
lives there well that was all going away
pretty soon so i told him i go george
you got to pick it up that's it i go
once you got to start paying child
support and her house payment and your
rent you know you can't rent
outrageously you can't go get a 2 grand
house because you're paying 15 under one
and you still got to pay child support
so you got to figure it out i was
busting those balls for a year i'm like
you better start looking for a part-time
job as a doorman at night you better do
something he took my advice and he he's
like you know what i'm gonna start my
own business he wholesales frames for
this guy okay but the guy is spreading
his business out then okay and george
sees it coming george already saw it
coming so he went to his sister his
sister originally had the framing shop
with the mother when she got married
they lived they moved away so she
couldn't help no more so the mother sold
the business in 85 and george has been
freelancing
since 85 not really with a home and it
really takes away from him
you know he rents a small office like
ours and he and he uh what he call that
[ __ ] he does the guy's wholesale work
but he's losing thousands of dollars a
month and george understands this he has
two daughters he was raising them he had
to drive him around so you just take
whatever you can so you can raise your
children but now the children you know
he gets one the daughter on the weekend
and every other weekend the one daughter
is older so he has more time so he was
telling me he's looking for a warehouse
so i told my wife last night you know
what
uh he's been getting up the last couple
fridays sunday mornings and going to
different uh farmer's markets
just to get his name out there and he's
doing oh good yeah like he was pissed
yesterday so he only sold two things but
his sister sold like eight things you
know but i go george you're getting out
there
and this is how people start you got to
get out there and he knows he goes i
don't know if it was a waste of money i
paid 250 to rent a booth i go what would
your options be would you be at home
watching tv or playing with your
daughter you're out there the only
nothing happens on the couch bro right
nothing [ __ ] has ever happened on the
couch yeah you want to stick your hand
in the couch and pull up 35 cents you
can do that all [ __ ] day and then
smell somebody else's [ __ ] on those
[ __ ] whatever but nothing happens on
the couch you know get out there and
it's funny so i told my wife i'm gonna
take those couple hundred i'm gonna give
it to george
to start up you know whatever he needs
man if i give him a thousand bucks to
start his little business up you know
and at that point like that thousand is
it's like twenty thousand like when you
when you when you're first starting out
or especially when uh
back to what you did for told me to do
for paula i'm making his day because
let's face it uh
when i bumped into george
uh
march of 85.
let's see what she's kicking in sorry oh
please
when i bumped into george in march of 85
when he was working as a land
and he was raking some of these leaves
in their backyard and i was burglarizing
the joint and i was casing the
neighborhood out and i saw him and
he opened me listen man i was two weeks
i was a month away from getting arrested
there's no two [ __ ] ways about it
guys and i was gonna do 10 years they
were gonna give me at least eight i had
no ties to the community
i just
i was robbing those [ __ ] gas stations
i was doing a thousand other things the
more spaghetti you stroke you know when
you're doing crime i used to do crime in
three
after three months you know something's
gonna go down
you can't do it for three months every
day like every day you got to get up and
make a living uh break into an apartment
sell nickel bags
eventually something's going to happen
there's it's going to store your [ __ ]
growth okay you're going to get arrested
somewhere some little mistake and i had
already gotten the rest of new york for
selling like a hot jewelry i sold hot
jewelry with an id and they came and got
me so i already knew it was around the
corner the width of
the police were around the corner you
know so when i bumped into george
i [ __ ] say what you want to say
george saved my life by ten years
you know george
uh gave me he let me stay with his
family for three months i helped him out
as much i could but i learned more in
those three months
george has been my brother since i was
15.
since freshman year high school george
karladinsky has been my brother i mean
guys all in all in you know when i met
people from cliffside they'd say to me
your friends are george [ __ ] it yeah
give him a drink front them a grandma
but whatever i needed because i was
friends with george growing up and it's
amazing that our friendship has lasted
uh
36 [ __ ] years
wow
and uh
you know i just want to make his day you
know he doesn't listen so he will never
know about this
but it's amazing get together jordy
should be listening no joy listen
he used to listen from his phone i think
i think he called in
yeah he's called then no worries but
it's just a
he'll he'll never know but it's it's
just amazing that sometimes you do have
to make somebody's day you really do man
just and it doesn't take a [ __ ]
diamond it doesn't take a dinner at ruth
chris
it's just a little [ __ ] gesture man
and i'm happy you did that lee i'm happy
we didn't we didn't tell him what we
tell him so we were driving down and
you're like when does paula start her
job i said tomorrow and you're like
here's what you do
you you get a nice card
you stick uh
whatever a hundred dollars is i don't
remember how you feel you have to think
you should you put it in there
any can you tell her
uh here's this go get your nails done
before the you start the job and you can
look pretty like something like that i'm
high now so it's sharp yeah i want your
feet and your fingers to look [ __ ]
sharp so i did that but i went i went to
the to the pharmacy to get a card and
there was one that was perfect it was
like i believe in you but it's a whole
big long poem of like i believe in
goodness because of you and and i just
started giggling and then there was this
one where this
was hairy caveman was like i'm a stupid
caveman and then i find you and then
i chose that one
and i put it in there and like i had to
go i'll put a whole hundred or five
twenty five twenties like i didn't just
christ i didn't have time to go get it
yeah
even i was picking her up the next day
so i picked her and her cousin up at
something i had to go drive her cousin
back
um
and i gave her the card once her cousin
got out of the car and she started
crying just because he was so happy and
i like it threw me for a loop because
like i've got her stuff that was more
expensive than that and it didn't have
that effect on her but it was just it
was it made me feel good making
somebody's [ __ ] day dog with the
littlest gesture
is the best thing you could do yeah even
calling somebody and going yo [ __ ]
wash that helmet hanging up on them
because they'll call you back go what
the [ __ ] is that and then they'll go to
work and go [ __ ] one of my friends
call me this morning told me to [ __ ]
get hung up on me and [ __ ] just little
things that you giggle at you know
listen at the end of the [ __ ] week
when you're laying in that casket and
you're ready
you're going to giggle one time right
you go that [ __ ] made my day you
know lubes used to always make my day
pick me up give me a valium
i got this joint for you uncle joey you
know whatever
you know this kid andrew made our day
when he you put this little thing
together this this you know we
some people well look at this what the
this took his time
this is great i love when people do
little things like this andrew put this
him and his girlfriend made a little
devil
the devil's getting a dick up the ass
the other two were in the corner they
already got [ __ ]
you know it's little things like that
that makes somebody's day sometimes so
sometimes you just call somebody and
tell me 11. where's the [ __ ] jam
where's i want to be around today it's
[ __ ] 6 45
get up [ __ ] it's a beautiful day
to be alive
make somebody's day but also make your
own [ __ ] day grab your [ __ ] loot
that [ __ ] flag what
your hon how stone do you lisa yet
medium
i'm not
medium yeah
well get ready that's a triple dose
let's do a vapor head you want to vape
i'm okay
okay so you were the highest i've ever
heard of yesterday
and then you wake up at six in the
morning and you want to do it i
i always like taking day you don't take
days off
like jeez i took friday and saturday off
you did none yes i did
oh
thank goodness
was the only better that why are you
depressing me
oh okay
look at these [ __ ] clouds from a
vapor pen
are you kidding me or what what are you
doing hit that [ __ ] and hold it
in you gotta hold it in it's good for
your lungs
what's that that's a junior [ __ ]
pilot head what the [ __ ]
you wanna listen you wanna navigate that
plane and lose it like the malaysians
did take a deep [ __ ] hit will you
deep deep deep in the lungs of death
someone said listen to tmz
don't worry donald sterling will be so
happy [ __ ] the nz [ __ ]
tmz
crime stopping and [ __ ] on people
that chick got in trouble she said
racist [ __ ] i like it i like it
you're a [ __ ] animal you put gel in
your head dude today you're smoking last
week you got a stop sign shirt on so
they got a green light on yeah
what do you got red and green shirt is
this [ __ ] santa claus and july
[ __ ] give me that
oh my god
that's a nice hit probably
that was a very [ __ ] nice hit
you [ __ ] up tony bennett to the hell
of it [ __ ] them up you just cut them
up into pieces
while leaving
that oh my god i'm gonna give some shout
outs to my main [ __ ] first off
to my main man happy birthday jovan
axeman [ __ ] my little brother kyle
donnelly raj dude adderall you bad
[ __ ] joey brooklyn looking good
lesten thomas i love you i always see
you [ __ ] with the hairdo
thomas heather you bad [ __ ]
javier 93 what are you nuts oh what or
what and camaro jeff
wash that [ __ ] it's monday
drives a camaro i don't [ __ ] know his
name is camaro jeff you gotta you know
you gotta tell him something what if he
drove like a mustang
well
he couldn't be commercial jeff anymore
like what if he just
listen just looks like he's not bad it
just looks straight at the screen like
your business what are you gonna bother
[ __ ] people for right isn't it i
don't know i don't know i wonder if he
drives the camera
i don't [ __ ] know i never asked him
why don't you get him on the phone
hook up camaro jeff and go come out jeff
maybe he likes [ __ ] camaros and he
has a cadillac now because he's got six
[ __ ] kids did you ever think of that
league i don't know what i'm gonna do
with this [ __ ] youth of america i got
my main man mike pyle
ufc fighter calling it at 7 a.m i love
mike pyle
i met him to eddie bravo yesterday i
[ __ ] up i did not go to eddie bravo
invitational last night
that was part of what made me feel very
bad last night i did not make eddie's
day yesterday i [ __ ] up
uh i thought the invitational started at
five my plan was to leave the house if i
was gonna leave i like to re try to do a
dunkin podcast
i was gonna do duncan's podcast hang out
with duncan for a little while and then
i was gonna shoot to the ebi okay and
sit there from like five to six thirty
and go home
and at least he did it with mercy and
bather but the invitational instructor
was 6 30.
and that's right in the middle of
[ __ ] you know good morning america in
my [ __ ] house
you know like
from five to seven in my house it's
[ __ ] chaos from 4 30 from the time we
get back from the park
till 8 o'clock it's just chaos even with
one little child
because we both eat sheets
you know i do some [ __ ] the phone rings
unnecessary i mean there's a thousand
things going on i don't know why
so it's very hard i can't go to jiu
jitsu at 7 30. it's very hard even for
me to go at eight o'clock at night
that's why i gotta go in the daytime
yeah today i can't go i got a bunch of
[ __ ] [ __ ] going on today
i wanted to go to kettlebell class i
can't [ __ ] go but the knee feels a
lot better
thank you for the people who sent me
emails and exercise programs you know
one thing about the [ __ ] church is
that
if you put it on twitter
if anybody from the church needs an
exercise program or a diet
or a [ __ ] personal trainer or
anything you know jeremy's around
guys put it on twitter just and say
attention church put something hashtag i
don't even know what a hashtag is
people sent me [ __ ] exercises
for my knee some [ __ ] kid a doctor
sent me a thing i could do with a ball
just to reduce the pain some other
people sent me a stuff i could put on it
like a lady sending me some type of
brace listen man i love you from
[ __ ] but you guys gotta spread
out amongst us we gotta start making
money you know we gotta start taking
care of each other not me i'm talking
about you guys as a whole you know
there's a lot of you guys that hit me up
from like i noticed a lot of people hit
me up lately from [ __ ] utah and
texas and houston you guys got to work
together in houston
because uh it's amazing all the [ __ ] all
the great exercises and little things
breathing every time i put that i have a
problem with something on here lee it's
[ __ ] amazing yeah it's amazing i at
least get three emails from people going
join you were wrong about this
try this and it and it really i don't
argue with people i take their advice
because maybe this is their [ __ ]
field
and nine out of ten it is their [ __ ]
field you know what i'm saying so if you
have something
put it on this twitter page on this what
they call them a thread i don't even
know
because it's very interesting the things
i've learned from [ __ ] you there's a
facebook fan page what's that there's a
facebook page for the church is there
some girl sent me a workout with a wall
like i think she was telling me that she
does this to rehab people
but she believes that if i do this
before the surgery
my knee would get strong i swear to
godly i did all three times last week
okay and the swelling went down whoa to
the t she goes this is what's gonna
happen then elevate it and isolate for
15 minutes and get back on and walk on
it for six minutes i mean this girl sent
me a [ __ ] thing so
thank you man thank you for all the love
you give us thank you for always
reaching out
thank you for always doing all that type
of [ __ ] i got some interesting i also
gotta you get good [ __ ] and you get bad
[ __ ] i got a very [ __ ] interesting
email like thursday from somebody and i
got it and i didn't look at it till
yesterday i didn't
this is how high i was last night
then in the three years or four years
i've been doing a podcast it's the
second time i didn't answer emails you
had gmail no i couldn't even look at
them i tried
i opened them up at about six and i
could not do it when the baby went to
take a bath yeah i ran in there real
quick just to see if i could knock off
ten of them yeah
i read one that [ __ ] made me cry so i
closed it and [ __ ] went up and sat
there
that's how [ __ ] high i was
that's how [ __ ] high i was it was
such a touching [ __ ] email about
somebody's family that i had to shut the
[ __ ] thing down and go laid on the
couch that's how
you know uh
it's amazing the things that you know
this is why we're trying to put i went
to look at couches this week okay and i
was i couldn't find couches that were
high enough i left sarah tiana message
i'm gonna bring the table over here and
we're working on the advice show it's
just gonna take a little while i wanna
make the studio look right on that side
i'm gonna put a perfect couch and i
wanna have the perfect pictures and
whatnot but it's uh it's amazing you
know we always get a vice count somebody
sent me a [ __ ] thread this week
from a web page where they were just
bashing me
yeah and it's hysterical but
it didn't bother me because they were
telling the truth okay they were telling
their opinion the truth you know the
other day we had a conversation about a
show i saw that i just did not think was
funny and how society thinks it's
[ __ ] hilarious
and these guys it was a thread that
somebody sent me i think it was from a
duncan trussell
uh web page or something is that what
you call them like
uh yeah a board
and they made some interesting points
i've always heard you should write back
no no no no i won't write back because
what i don't want it to become
it's not a confrontation or something
something hey listen man
uh i don't i never peep okay i never
[ __ ] peep
okay a lot of people always say don't
google yourself i know people google
themselves constantly and find someone i
don't want to see nothing i don't want
to hear my voice i don't give a [ __ ]
yeah but it's so weird that somebody
sent me this and said look what i found
i guess on somebody's web page threat or
a board yeah is that what you call them
and
it was just you know you know 15 [ __ ]
pages of hate of uh not
some
intelligent hatred and i understood it
the same way i would explain i just
wouldn't say something sucks
you know they they said some people said
that uh
joe rogan was selling all of us that
they didn't think i was funny or it was
funny after people thought joe and
duncan were funny
they thought that uh i was a slime ball
and arya was a [ __ ] idiot you know
whatever and it was very weird to read
you know um
what do you feel like when you read that
you just feel
disconnected but i understand no i'm not
that type of person i'm not a hypocrite
like that i get it i [ __ ] get it i
like listen once in a while listen if
you want to hit me and go i don't like
what you do that's fine yeah i i
appreciate that it's when you hit me and
insult me
there's a big difference hey you fat
bastard [ __ ] your stupid [ __ ] show
okay
it's on
but if you want to hit me with an email
or something like that like a gentleman
and go listen i listen to your show it's
vulgar
you're racist or you're [ __ ]
insensitive or you smoke dope
some guy wrote i'll tell you what some
guy wrote that he never paid attention
to me
ralphie may jackie gleason or any other
comedian that's fat
because why would you listen to a public
figure if they were obese
that was the one that made me laugh
that uh you would never a comedian
should be in shape you know whatever
that was the one so comedian should just
be very attractive
that was how shallow this [ __ ]
was
uh hasn't paid much attention to comedy
right hasn't and that's why
you have to
you know one guy said we were one trick
pony that rogan talks about certain
subjects and i talk about certain
subjects over and over again all right
tremendous that's the subjects we know
i'm not going to talk about something i
don't know and be a [ __ ] false about
it i'm not going to come out here and
make believe i know about everything you
know i don't know about it i don't know
about anything i know about two or three
[ __ ] things
down to the y but that's it and i've
grown from there but it's uh the one
that the only thing that bothered me was
that people called me a liar that was
the one i didn't like for sure yeah but
there was a lot of people on the thread
that also made viable points
all right there he is
mr pyle what's happening brother
what's up jd good morning my friend
thank you very much for taking the time
and calling me what's going on over
there
oh now i'm just getting just everybody's
up for the day now how's the baby
he's fantastic he's in there he's in
there eating right now as a matter of
fact 10 months old
10 10 months is he walking
oh yeah he's walking all over the place
man all over the place and how do you
feel
all right great because it's awesome to
for your son to walk to you and lift his
arms up for you to pick him up and hold
him
it's tough for you to leave the house
anymore huh
yeah it is it really is it really is
i didn't even make it to eddie's
invitational last night because of my
house so
uh
after we spoke
i couldn't do it man it was sunday and
there was too much going on and there
was fish sticks and
wally kazam and i bought her a scooter
and you know
uh yeah it's uh there's a new there's a
new boss in the house man and that's all
there is to it
i don't care how tough how tough you are
how badass you are how
how mean you might of a person you might
be or whatever a a kid will will soften
you up in a second
your own kid your own kid will soften
you up in one second man
no it's uh it's a weird thing what's
going on in your world are you training
i am i am i will be i will be going
um just probably a couple hours after
i'm i'm i'm through talking with you
and do you have a fight
you'll probably have me so pumped up
i'll i'll go and
bash somebody when i get to the gym oh
please i need i need for you to go into
like a [ __ ] savage today what do you
got today you got you got striking you
got conditioning you got jiu jitsu you
got everything today yeah hey i think
it's going to be mma orientated um
uh
training today i'll probably leave
i'll be i'll leave the class today
because uh owner
is out doing a reality show right now so
i'll step in and fill his shoes until he
gets back until he gets back being
famous
and then um
leave the guys a little bit and then
maybe choke a couple of them out and
then come home
it's amazing the life you guys lead man
i i [ __ ] love it i've learned so much
from
watching uh mma i've learned so much and
applied it to comedy you know
but you've been around you're the real
[ __ ] deal you are the real deal my
friend
been around a long time in this game
anyway
as young as it is i've been around
um
almost
as long as this existed
as long as it uh existed almost
um one of the fights when you fought
somebody mentioned that your first fight
was against rampage jackson
in memphis
yeah yeah actually that was probably
where my that was actually about my
fifth fight
it was rampage first thought it was
around my fifth fight
i don't remember uh
i didn't remember any of the names of my
opponents so you know of course sure dog
couldn't honor it and just you know put
up some magical number up there with no
names decided but uh but anyway um
yeah that still nevertheless just you
know firefight then you're fighting a
beast like him
a big big man and
i was way out of my weight class
my guy had gotten hurt
and the older called me and said well
you know he was real tight
this guy got hurt whatever
you know a little 175 pound uh
which was the uh was the weight limit
and i said well i want to fight who you
got he said well we got that that guy
that howls you know like a wolf all the
time i said let's buy him
so yeah well he's 200 and he's 210
pounds you know so i don't give a [ __ ]
let's fight
i'm ready to fight
so
he did
and uh well the rest is history
i got thrown around a little bit slammed
around i got picked up thrown out of the
ring
into my into my corners uh arms a little
bit and they just kind of just shoved me
back underneath the bottom rope and told
me to go get after it
now let me ask you something mike when
you were younger before that were you a
fighter did you get into many fights
did you have good hands
no you know actually i i was a good kid
um i go redneck
uh
a small town
um
you know i spent my time
on a pond somewhere fishing or
just at home running around the woods or
something like that you know what i mean
um but you know they're
my mom moved
i went to five i think
four different schools in my lifetime so
you know we've had little pricks you
have to
you know slap around a little bit so
they leave you alone um
got into a few fights like that
you know just
kids being kids and picking on the new
guy and
then the new guy whoops their ass and
then what they spend they want to be
friends with you
um but other than that no not not really
a lot of uh
not really a lot of fights maybe
probably grew up
maybe 10 10
of fights growing up on me
and yes joey i'm going every single one
of them and come through fashion
now let me ask you this what was your
first art did you
learn wrestling first or jiu jitsu or
taekwondo was my first at 18 years old
that's when you joined at 18.
what's that you joined taekwondo at 18
yep i was 18 years old about to turn 19.
i wanted to do that
because
my little cousin he was seven
uh his mom was taking him to taekwondo
all the time and i was always
i was always interested in taekwondo to
begin with because i mean i'm sorry uh
martial arts because i grew up
you know watching chuck norris and
and uh bruce lee
you know so that was
i was always proud to watch one of those
movies up that was that was my that was
my [ __ ] i loved
i loved martial arts
it's just that the small towns that
we always lived in never had um
you know access to a martial arts gym
that was it was just too small
this is the way it is
so this is when you were in dresden
yep
that was when i was in well well no
actually i i moved away from dresden
um
when i was 17 i thought i thought i was
a big boy and i needed to go out into
the world and pay bills and have bills
and [ __ ] like that
i thought i was big and tough
so i left home 17
moved to alabama
with my cousin
who was a
a lot of them a lot older than me with
children
and her children were in taekwondo and
that's what
that's why i um
joined taekwondo because you know they
were going and i could drive them there
and you know things like that i was
already driving and you know going and
picking them up occasionally anyway so i
watched the class and i'm like well this
is interesting
but it just wasn't tough enough for me
you know that taekwondo the um
they just kind of they just kind of you
know tag they just play tag you know i
mean i don't really hit each other you
wanted to rock and roll you were ready
to rock and roll i was i wanted to rock
and roll so
she let me kind of get a little bit more
um an instructor kind of let me get a
little bit more uh you know a little bit
more physical with one of the adults
that were there that was an old
kickboxer
and um
and he should have
that's the first time i actually ever
felt a liver shot in my life
um
he kicked me in my liver and i hit the
floor
whining
and uh trying to gasp for breath i
thought my god that is awesome
that is that is a powerful painful
technique i have to do that to someone
one day i'm gonna do that when i grow up
but anyway that guy he kind of you know
turned me on to being
what it is
to be tough and what it really feels
like
to to use a martial art in a more
physical way than than taekwondo was
allowing me
you know with the rules and things like
that but
he didn't
he didn't seem to care to whip on me at
all but uh i thank him for that and it
made me tough
um
and
uh
and that's that'll either it'll either
make you or break you you know at that
point you're like well this is a little
too physical for me let's go back to tag
and tag one another class
but um
i stuck with it and
um
[ __ ] became the toughest song bitching
dresden
it's amazing uh
how this happens like you go into a gym
one day you know whenever i talk to
fighters i always expect them to say
well i beat the [ __ ] out of everybody i
fought after 12. no
it's the other way around you when it
walked into something and it evolved and
one day you're like you know what man i
could do this [ __ ]
i could [ __ ] do this
i couldn't imagine getting punched in
the face for a [ __ ] living
you know i could take a [ __ ] knuckle
to the head or something and hopefully
not go down but
to do it for a living mike powell i
respect the [ __ ] out of you guys and to
evolve
to keep evolving you know mike
every time you fight you got to get a
little
better yeah you have to because hell the
other guy is the thing the thing is with
the
with the way it's going now for me
i went through all the stages
and all the changes that the mmas went
through you know
i started trading when it was
i was
you know fighting when it was real holds
bar
and then it was
then it was in hb remember remember that
nhb yeah
they abbreviated it to make it sound a
little you know a little more uh
sophisticated unhv fighter and you know
i was an hb fighter i was
i went through all those
times where you know you basically kind
of had a guy who
um
was a
that barely could punch
and you knew you were going to be in a
wrestling match and you knew you're
going to be wrestled right but you know
times that
times have changed
everybody's getting better and now
everybody can wrestle their ass off they
can punch very well you know they can
kick they can grapple they can submit
they can you know [ __ ] are
jumping off cages and
inside kicking people in the face you
know and it's just
you know i've been there since the
beginning and
and now
better coaches as far as strength and
conditioning and better uh more
open-minded striking coaches
um having you know have gotten into the
game and evolved and started and now is
starting to produce some
um
very
very good
fighters because they got
you know a good grasp
and a good idea of
you know what's going on with the sport
and
you know and they they know what the
hell they're doing it's not just a
boxing coach or just a wrestling coach
or
you know etc
now we're starting to develop some you
know young guys that you know five years
ago come in when they were eighteen
now they're you know in their mid middle
twenties and
the first thing they were doing was
mixed martial arts not
karate or type oh yeah
here you go you gotta take down wrestle
punch kick grapple submit and all that
[ __ ] you ready to go
you know what i mean so
and there's been some good coaches that
involved and and now retired and been in
the game back in the day and that you
know and been around it and you know
the sports young was like 20 20 years
old do this
you know
i mean
20 years is not anything that's nothing
for a sport
you know to evolve and grow that's 20
years is nothing and look where it's at
now
there's just nothing more fascinating
than
um two guys pitted against one another
to and
and you know and it's just a human chess
match you know they're getting after it
man and it's been
i mean it's it's as humans we've
documented it over the thousands of
years that we've been on this earth
and you know you see all the
even down to hieroglyphics people are
you know they can show a couple of dudes
wrestling grappling
um and then you know back in the roman
days guys you know the gladiators i mean
it's just it's infatuating fighters are
fighters always be around
until the end of time because
because it's just the ultimate
you know
it's just the coolest yeah soccer
players are cool basketball players are
cool but
you get to sit down and pick a fighter's
brain or talk to him about
fighting
it's just it's just uh
it's just something that will always
remain interesting i mean because we are
a small
small percentage of the human race we're
zero zero zero point i don't know five
or so i don't know i haven't haven't
crushed numbers but
the people that walk to earth that do
what we do
it's a very small small number and
people are you know even boxers you know
i mean and put us all together in boxers
and
and um mma fighters it's a small small
small world and community
but a lot of us out there that's
able to do it you know
um it's interesting it's interesting to
sit and and
talk to a fighter or
or watch it
it's you know like i say it's part of
history and it always will be
the
humans beating the hell out of one
another
people will stop and watch it every time
it's so [ __ ] interesting you're right
no hey listen man
hey man you're walking down the street
and then a soccer game breaks out and
you're gonna keep walking
you know you're gonna keep on walking
you're going to walk on are you walking
by and baseball field they're playing
baseball yeah so what you're going to
keep talking to your buddy about
um that new engine that you're going to
put in your trans am tomorrow or
whatever but you start you're walking by
a park and to do start scrapping you're
going to you're going to stop and you're
going to watch it
you really are something that's
captivated it's captivating it's
interesting
to watch people
you know especially at the level that
you know that ufc has has um
you know brought the mma community
um
you know as far as knowledge and
and
exposing the fighters to the public and
letting them understand that
uh you know hey look
we're not a bunch of uh you know dumb
knee heads that um
that just get in the cage because we
like fighting
you know
it's a it's an art it's a it's a skill
set where we are professional athletes
just the same as a
basketball player or a football player
or we prepare you know we have to
prepare we're we're professional
athletes now and you know and
ufc has done a really great job at
getting that point across and
exposing the fighters to the public so
they can shake their hand
and talk with them you know it's not
that often you get to sit and talk with
your favorite uh golf player or football
player
or
or whatever but you know you see us
everywhere
you know we're approachable
um
for the most part intelligent
um
you know there's
you know and friendly you know it's it's
a it's a great sport man
no i i love it i i love what it's what's
happening with it you know when i first
watched the ufc i didn't know what the
[ __ ] was going on
10 15 years ago i wasn't too crazy about
it
but i started paying attention after i
saw anderson beat up chris leave me
i just had it on my tv when that fight
was happening and once i saw anderson
silva i'm like oh this is beautiful i
was really into it
and after that i became a fan and i
became a fan of your lives
i like your lives i like that
exactly it's just not two guys beating
each other up and during a week juicing
and going to a bar
it's a you know people have families
you're a family man you're not out you
know [ __ ] having orgies every night
you're a family guy you get up you go
down there you do your training and you
go back home and now you have to be this
different person here you are
in your mind three hours earlier your
focus is on uh breaking somebody's
shoulder whatever i'm you know you're in
the [ __ ] cage uh
practicing you know you have to get your
mind set up and now you got to go home
and shut that off and pick up a child
and
you know wash a dish and tell your wife
your lover it's brilliant that you have
those two different mindsets but just
what goes into being a fighter not just
a ufc fighter
but the whole thing we were talking
about dedication this morning mike
powell that people think that you
just uh do jumping jacks and hit a bar a
bag all day
there's so much more
i wish it was and even for comedy
there's people think that you get up at
two and we just get on stage and crack a
microphone and smoke a joint
i'm 51 i [ __ ] work harder now you got
a right you got to prepare you got you
know and and i can't even imagine being
a fighter the the nutrition the [ __ ]
the jiu jitsu the the the wrestling the
the the running the conditioning and
then
and then
oh my god and then you gotta pray that
you stay healthy
that the guy's not rolling next to you
and he bumps into your ankle that
because you know there's freak accidents
yep
so it's such time man all the stars have
to be aligned your head has to be right
you know
uh it just i give you guys so much
[ __ ] props
on the preparation that america doesn't
see
america doesn't see the preparation that
goes into you know they work nine to
five they were their focus is on other
parts they just you know turn on fox
sports on saturday and they're like look
at these [ __ ] savages they don't
understand you know even with pro
football they don't understand that that
[ __ ] starts every [ __ ] monday that
there's film to watch and you got to
prepare for their defense and prepare
for their offense you know this is the
same any professional but what you guys
have done
has really uh taken it to the next level
in preparation and you especially you're
a [ __ ] badass savage your last fight
you were a [ __ ] savage a savage but i
think ronda rousey was on the card so
they forgot about my brother mike
[ __ ] pyle you know what i'm saying
it's like when uh rocky's coach went to
talk to rocky to try to get him to
manage him the first time he's telling
him why you need a manager because he
knocked out whatever but it was the same
night that joe lewis knocked out so
nobody knew what happened but i saw what
happened i saw what happened you came
out like a [ __ ] savage your movie
thai skills were all over the place
that's why i love you mike bob plus
you're from [ __ ] uh
the best place ever i love all that
stuff out there that's why i married my
wife after i went to see a family
and i saw those hills and how they eat
those squirrels i was [ __ ] in jack
how they eat those girls
they do my wife's family eats squirrels
i made
uh more than one occasion and how big
are they when you eat them how big are
they
ain't that small man about as big as
your foot
and you deep fry them right my wife deep
fries i'm like chicken yeah you could
deep fry them you can
you can make you make a stew out of it
do whatever just whatever you do with
any other meat except for bacon look at
my co-host the flying jew he's freaking
out what you don't need squirrels dog
i'm so high right now thought i'm eating
a squirrel oh
i'm telling you like
a little fried squirrel with some
[ __ ] mashed potatoes lee you'll be
jumping up and down oh yeah
oh there you go that's a good [ __ ]
when is your next fight what are they
saying
uh well i asked for a after august and
the email reply was i will get you a
fight in august
yeah they had a couple cards coming up
so
yeah i could you know what i couldn't
even tell you who what's going on in the
next cards or whatever so many oh my god
blowing up so big so fast
man i'm i'm
and all these new names coming on you
know on board i mean [ __ ] i can't i can
hardly keep up with
myself and get into the gym and
you know like you said coming home being
bad it's like damn who's fighting next
oh fight oh there's a fight wednesday
and saturday okay all right all right
every week there's almost a fight it's
awesome it's blowing up man you know
what they were just in berlin and brazil
and
now they're coming back home here in the
states it's just nuts man it's nice well
the fight's this weekend because i know
this fight saturday
this [ __ ] fight saturday brother the
seventh and this fights the 15th i mean
this fights the next three weeks i think
what do you think lee what do you see
there
it's it's either a johnson against
somebody it's [ __ ] it's blowing up
it's
demarcus defending his belt
it's uh ben henderson and oh no yeah
that's right
and where are they fighting
it's interesting
maybe jimmy varner let me look at it no
it's not jamie vaughn oh here we go oh
he just henderson versus
cabela the russian dude yeah all right
yeah so cool yeah
yeah
oh [ __ ]
sanchez was a piercing
oh yeah yeah that big weird hat yeah
that was weird oh that's who's fighting
him that guy against ben henderson oh my
god what are they fighting out of
albuquerque oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] you might have to jump in the
car and go down and report directly from
[ __ ] albuquerque you know what i'm
saying oh my god no no stop at the
indian reservation get ten dollars in
quarters
my wife is half indian her family up
there in tennessee that
my mother said
who
it's how man not food how who you know
you got to be careful with the indians
they're [ __ ]
they get pissed off they get mad at the
braves can you imagine what they'll do
to us oh yeah they'll get mad they're
getting mad i got a there's a friend of
mine here that's um
uh
i don't know how much indian but i mean
he
looks you know a lot
um indian i think paiute tried that you
know that that um
was out here he's a cool cat uh he loves
his beer
loves his beer he's a beer man he's a
brew master
out here
got it got his got his tribe got his
tribe tattooed on the inside of his lip
that's when you know you're [ __ ]
dedicated to the tribe my friend the
crips don't do that [ __ ]
let me ask you something
the blood runs what
let me ask you something what gym do you
train at now
syndicate
and what syndicate who's over there with
you
dummy kid is uh
it's been uh jim that you probably
remember the name it used to be okay
started out back in the day
more than 10 years ago combat club then
then
he joined forces with zion then become
zion
training center out here
then um he joined forces with the uh
warrior gym
um then that didn't
pan out then he was then it became a
throwdown
gym
and that didn't work out with the you
know partnerships and all that so then
he said the hell it was gonna go solo
call it syndicate okay
and then who knows john wood
said that he's been the owner of all
those names and saying jim just changed
the name on the outside right um you
know for
10 years now
10 years plus his [ __ ] his sign guy
must love him
right
the guy that makes his signs [ __ ]
loves him he's like oh here we go well
there's uh
the bank's gotta love him when every
time he changes llc oh jesus
pay some more [ __ ]
so you're fighting out of syndicate now
those are your trainers
yep those are those training yep yep a
train uh boxing coach uh is
is actually more of a private boxing
coach not part of the gym that's jimmy
gifford
and then uh another another one of my
striking coaches that i use uh for the
most part all the time is uh nate pettit
and he's he's out of syndicate gym
and then i'm out of you know syndicate
you know john john wood who owns the gym
been a real close friend of mine ever
since i moved out here
to vegas and uh i've always you know
always went to his gym his gym has
always been close to my house and
usually is always the closer gym and i
used to you know because i used to be
out of the extreme couture right i
remember
and uh but i was only you know once or
twice a week i was over at my buddy's
gym anyway i just represented um you
know couture's gym and then
um
so i parted ways from there um
from syndicate
i'm sorry from uh
um couture
yeah from coutures and then uh you know
just started going over there you know
solely and completely you know like i
was talking about you know evolving in
the sport and things like that i got to
the point where the team the team aspect
of everything is great um don't don't uh
get me wrong um
but uh there's
i just felt like i was at a point in my
career where it was either [ __ ] or get
off the pot because i'm 38 right now
joey
i'm getting old i'm an old man when it
comes to this sport
young man in life but for the sport i'm
getting old right
um
so i needed to make a change i needed to
get more focus on
on mike pyle
i needed to get the coaching staff
around mike pyle not not a uh extreme
couture uh
team
um it's you know it's it's hard for a
coach to walk the floor when there's 20
guys on the floor
and and and seven of them are getting
ready to fight in two weeks
or three weeks
and and get that kind of focus and that
attention that you need
in that um
in that focus and
things like that you know that that you
need from your coaches and your coaching
staff and things like that it's
it's uh it's hard for a coach to walk
the floor and and
you know work with 20 guys
at the same time
right but
so i've made a change
i'm gonna what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
hire
a coach
on
for my camp
where every day
at this time
and this time
my
people are there whether it be five
people that's on board or whether it be
two people that's on board they're right
there and they're all about mike pyle
winning on whatever date it is and
that's what their focus is
and that is and that that's what flipped
the script for me
i had dropped a couple in the ufc and i
was about out
if i would have lost another one
i would have been gone
probably you know
due to the history of other other
fighters that could make it look like
that was you know next for me
you know because
you lose too much then you're not that
interesting that's just the way it is
it's just it's cut throat that way
um
so once i got that focus and i dialed
all that in i made a turn around in my
career um and it was a
very needed
uh thing for me because i've reached
such a a point where
joey i don't want to go nowhere else ufc
is where it's at yeah i don't want to go
anywhere else at the top of the heat
um all the those other organic
organizations that are out there they're
great
right
but
at ufc is where it's at that's where i
fought
my ass off to get to and that's where
i'm going to stay until i'm done
fighting i make the decision when i'm
done fighting right i'm not going
anywhere else so
i have this [ __ ] to get off the plot
so i did i made the change
left the team
aspect
brought my guys on
um
if i'm fighting a wrestler a very very
good wrestler then i'll hire i'll hire a
guy
who was a very good wrestler to come in
for my camp for eight weeks i was
throwing down a check i said here's a
check
does this number work for you
do you want to come take some time out
of your life
to help me win
that night
uh if so here's that check if not then
you know i understand because that's a
big commitment you know six to eight
weeks gone away from if it's a you know
family man he'd be gone if it's it just
doesn't matter you know you're out of
your home for six you know weeks from
anywhere
you know it's tough so
everybody's got to eat you know um
so break them off hey you want to be
part of it yes and the coaches they're
on board already they know what they're
getting
um
the the training partners that i bring
in they know what they're getting um you
know it's a very specific
um
structure that uh that i have now
and uh it's it's been great you know i
dropped a couple of fights here and
there but
you know it's to you know it's just some
bad boys you know they're not slouches
you know according to wikipedia you're
eighteen two in the last ten fights
yeah what are you you know you're rating
two though i thought i was gonna say you
were four on one
and the last cup you know i know you
went down to matt brown
which just went by the blink of a
[ __ ] eye it wasn't like and i know
you beat the [ __ ] out of story and there
was another one there and then the one
in february so you were never out of the
game brother you were always in there
and i know i hey listen self-criticism
you're talking to captain [ __ ]
self-criticism i hate myself
so when i go on stage and i miss a joke
and i forget i [ __ ] go back to my
room
and beat myself up that night you know
and then the next day i see it's just a
joke or whatever
but if you want to keep doing what we're
doing we got to pick this [ __ ] up
so no you're you're a [ __ ] savage
brother
38 it's just a [ __ ] number you look
good
you keep you know you're light you
haven't taken uh
that many of your ones what did you
fight at 170 don't you right 155 once
170. yeah 170 i probably woke up on 87
about 17 pounds over i never really you
know i'm not a big i'm not a big guy i'm
just i've always been you know tall and
lanky you know so
not too big of a welterweight but
right in the middle there i guess
and you got heart man i see it when you
fight i see how you walk around you know
i've known you a couple years and i've
always loved you when i found out where
you were from i even loved you more you
know i love rednecks that's my dream i
didn't want to be cuban or i want to be
a [ __ ] redneck dog because then i had
an excuse to shoot a [ __ ] you
understand me when you got an american
flag on your truck you got an excuse to
shoot a [ __ ] i'm cuban now
they'll throw me in jail
but you know i'm not asking that just to
be driving down the road and take a shot
down on the back
right off the right off your gun rack
out of your truck
just take it off the rack
step out shoot whatever the hell it is
you're shooting out there no matter
where you're at ain't nobody gonna hear
it and then put your you put it back in
to the truck
visible to everyone go to the post
office and drop the mail off shotgun
still sitting right there and no one
blinks an eye or or all the cops because
this [ __ ] can't see that guy's got a
shotgun in their window
you know when i was young growing up in
jersey i was so sh i didn't know i
thought texas is the way you went to be
a redneck
so i was gonna pick up my bags i loved
everything texas i loved the i loved the
houston rockets i liked the dallas
cowboys i didn't even know about [ __ ]
tennessee and what was cracking that
until i got older
but uh you know i i've told you a couple
of times my wife is going back in june
and we're definitely getting the house
an hour outside of nashville somewhere
like i'm done okay
i'm doing it how are you doing i'm
really happy i want to move back that i
want to move closer to her family
you know i like that little one let that
little one grow up
with with a yard and all the trees and
and
grow up that way man no i'm with you i
really like that i love it i want
property i don't want to spend
you know uh four hundred thousand
dollars and have a [ __ ] neighbor i
want to whack off him
i want to whack off in the [ __ ] yeah
you know oh yeah would you eat up on the
back porch and looking out over the
the uh
the fog rolling through the trees way
back in there maybe a deer walking by
you'll be in your underwear just
chilling maybe and if you needed to take
a piss you just stand up and piss off
the side of the porch oh
i love all that [ __ ] i love i'm sick and
tired of traffic you know somebody a
couple people i've said this before i
want to move to
nashville and i've gotten emails from
people that it's very racist and i'm
like you know what man people [ __ ]
hate people everywhere if i don't like
traffic yeah i don't attract those
people so i don't give a [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying i don't give a [ __ ] i
don't racist about wanting to move to
nashville i know how the [ __ ] you know
everywhere you move there's racism
everywhere you know so it's like shut
the [ __ ] up
i go to nashville my wife's best friend
is black they talk every [ __ ] day on
the phone she's andrea bobo she's in
[ __ ] memphis now you know my my niece
is in new york my niece who just
graduated from
bradford
they took him for a two-week trip
tonight they're going to a yankee game
[ __ ]
they're in new york city so you want to
see a player here
there's racism everywhere you go i i
grew up with with with uh i grew up
i grew up um
just i guess i would say just
out of being dirt poor
just a little bit higher than that i
guess whatever that would be
um but we had
i mean
we we were all living together black
folks white folks all down in those
neighborhoods man
one of my good friends growing up name
was tojo
that was his given name his name was
tojo that was my boy we go hunt birds
with bb guns every day after school i
wonder what old tojo is up to nowadays
hunting [ __ ] birds or bb guns
you never know my brother i'm gonna see
you july 18th all right you're gonna
you're gonna come with the wife
i'll see you at the south point i love
you mike powell and i and i wish you
nothing but luck i wish you would have
done the show earlier i was always
embarrassed to ask you but you're a
[ __ ] great guy man
i'll probably anytime that you wanted
for me to come on i'll definitely do it
i love you mike powell have a great week
give your son a kiss and i'll see you
july 18th with the flying jew all right
say goodbye
all right brother say goodbye buddy
all right man have a great week thank
you
that's a great [ __ ] guy man i love
him every time i see him you know he he
got eddie bravo in the movie
with mickey rourke they all played
prisoners he's been in movies mike pogba
wow yeah
mike's a good guy you know i'm very
fortunate to
to go to wayne's and talk to these guys
and whenever you do comedy shows they
show up and stuff what's up lee syed
you look for your [ __ ] high what's
the problem
uh no no no problem
let me talk let me just give a shout out
to you squish some of that down that
wasn't just a quarter no stop what are
you gonna do you're beautiful it's
[ __ ] monday what else you got going
on i got a lot of [ __ ] to do what do you
got to do i move it on thursday and i
gotta pack okay what about the walk
today you're gonna take a walk today he
didn't walk yesterday
what am i supposed to do dog
you see how high i am listen you go home
you get your [ __ ] ipod with the jews
jumping up and down the techno music and
you go through a walk then you're gonna
almost have a panic attack listening to
him talking about people beating each
other up in the park i started thinking
about gladiators look quickly look at me
stone to the gills this is what i'm
talking about people get your [ __ ]
together it's monday [ __ ]
who gives a [ __ ] what i'm still thinking
on it for all your [ __ ] needs all
your supplemental needs if you're not
going to honor.com he's still giggling
checking out what they got then you're
slipping you understand me honest got
the
what do they got they got the hemp
protein oh they got the alpha brain who
fought it they yeah
no did you smell that before it was
tremendous
anyway they got the [ __ ] um they got
the the alpha brand they got the shroom
tech they got the new mood
but listen they're [ __ ] cutting edge
technology you feel good
i went to beginner jiu jitsu friday
night
and i took two of those shroom techs and
i'll tell you what i did phenomenal the
energy it gives you towards the end i
did phenomenal you feel good
you breathe in bed i'm sorry i'm burping
this is [ __ ] water
and that edible made me burp uh
just go to [ __ ]
honor.com from kettlebells to weighted
vests to ropes
on it is always doing something ahead of
everybody else and i'm not you know if
you go all these other health websites
yeah they're okay and they've got good
protein powders and whatnot and they got
a money-back guarantee you don't like
what they do you [ __ ] especially with
the alpha brain i mean who else [ __ ]
puts that out for brain you take you
take a cycle alpha brain you see how
good you feel you feel alert you feel
alive your eyes are [ __ ] well you
smell the fat of the burp no no no just
like
who else makes out for brain no only one
company no one else can make up right
but what the [ __ ] you talking this is
what i'm saying to you when it comes to
nootropics alpha brains the [ __ ]
go to honor.com you like what you see go
to jerrydears.net go to the on that box
and press church
c-h-u-r-c-h get 10 percent off go on the
stay on it program they'll send you your
stuff directly every [ __ ] month the
beginning of the month you don't go to
dilly dally and get back on the web page
just like my people at dollar shave club
those bad [ __ ] this is the
first ingrown hair i've gotten in months
right here i don't know why you see that
[ __ ] lean it looks like a [ __ ]
pepperoni [ __ ] slice it's big i
popped it this morning i woke up i had a
lump on my [ __ ] side what [ __ ] what
what what
yeah i popped that's why i told you i
popped it by mistake i scratched it i
didn't know what it was but it doesn't
matter dollar shave club i looked and
see i looked at the blades the other day
i looked at the handle the other day how
good the handle was the blade listen if
you're [ __ ] around where you guys are
going down to a supermarket you gotta
wait online you're spending [ __ ] 20 a
month and that's just on blade and
razors alone cut this [ __ ] they gotta
program one dollar six dollars and nine
dollars you get to pick what you want
for your needs the tenderness of your
beard whether you want an aloe strip go
to dollar shave club go see what they
got to offer if you like it go to
joeydiaz.net go to dollar shave club box
and press in church
c-h-u-r-c-h don't sound so [ __ ]
enthusiastic
i know i am because uh girls can use it
too because paula stole mine that's what
i'm saying and you shave your monkey
it's got a good handle it's heavy your
hand won't slip with those plastic ones
you got no guidance if there's a burp or
you fought you you'll slit your [ __ ]
[ __ ] not with dollar [ __ ] shave club
go to the dollar shave club go to the
box and press church search
church you dirty [ __ ] suckers always in
the world of entertainment i always try
to hook you [ __ ] up whether
it's razors whether it's supplements let
me come at you with my main
[ __ ] hulu plush you can watch
the hulu plus and so much more you
understand you got modern family the
daily show scandal and you can watch
every episode of nashville lost and
doctor who you get ad-free movies and
you get kids shows [ __ ] too you can
play them on any computer smart tv roku
apple tv xbox playstation pretty much
any streaming device you got at the
[ __ ] house an iphone your foot your
fungi toenail hulu plus is there for you
go to hulu plus see what they got if you
like what you see go to hulu plus box on
joeydiaz.net and press impression joey
joey j-o-e-y you bad [ __ ]
and start your program at 7.99 a month
but i'm gonna give you two weeks off
two weeks for free
two weeks for free who gives you two
weeks for [ __ ] free who tell me who
nobody [ __ ] go to huluplus.com
go to the box and press in joey joey
j-o-e-y also to one of my favorite
people in the world i love jeremy i love
talking to him on the phone he always
got answers for me go to escape
podtank.com let me tell you something
for all your tangles look at the shape
of this [ __ ] mooc
for all your tank for all your
flotation tank needs whether it's
industrial residential ain't [ __ ]
around over there you understand me you
got a question you called germany on the
1-800 line they got the just the tank
model if you go over there tell them i
sent you got a buck 50 off if you go to
any other tank whether it's commercial
residential you get 250 off if you
mention joeydears.net or whatever the
[ __ ] you want to mention joey diaz lee
gigglin you know look at look at this
look i got to put up
look what i got to put up with people a
little piece of [ __ ] cheebuck too
he's giggling he's crying
he's going to walk the denny's going to
walk to denny's now you're going to get
the two two of those [ __ ] five
packages aren't you anyway go to
escape.tank.com they're tremendous i
hear nothing but great things about them
they'll help you all the way through
mention joey diaz mentioned the church
you get 250 off but let me tell you what
the best part about this man they're
there with your customer service is the
most important thing with your flotation
device you don't want to get in there
and swim in sperm this stuff is [ __ ]
tremendous if you want to get in your
house they'll help you 1-800 call jeremy
go to escape.tank.com mention the church
and get 250 off this i gotta deal with
this [ __ ] why are you giggling so
much what's the matter which i ain't
even saying nothing funny i'm just
talking about [ __ ] our sponsors you
have a little respect here lee you have
a little respect goodness he said
something very funny what i say he said
the [ __ ] is wrong with you
what'd i say look at this
and i gotta tell you something about i
listened to what what what what i'm
going to keep talking
i'm sorry
look you're talking about i got nothing
to say
until you [ __ ] stop giggling what is
it
ladies and gentlemen this poor [ __ ]
kid shot the deck you know what's crazy
man uh
i've been [ __ ] up lately i've been a
little [ __ ] up lately
it's amazing how hard it is to really
write a book it really really is i got
to give props to the people who are
authors anybody who writes a blog
uh but what's really hard is when you
write a biography i've been hooking up
my little editor jessica who i love
daily who are great she really is great
and she's really got the language down
and uh
she's a hard worker and whatnot but the
beauty of it is we sat down this week
and we probably talked to three close to
four hours we broke down three chapters
and i'll tell you something it sucked
the [ __ ] wind out of me are we
bring that open or well being that open
uh you know because i had made notes
you know you just don't it's not like i
just sit there and rattle off [ __ ] i
learn i have to
i have to take a week
and make little notes about everything i
remember about that area
and then i put it all together and then
when i'm putting it together i remember
some
other specific thing that was in there
okay so it takes time so when i get
together with her on tuesdays
uh we just sit there and we discuss the
chapters and it's a lot you know what
you're people going to get a way better
book because she's involved you're going
to get a tremendous book because she's
involved because she's
sucking the energy out of me she's
taking these stories out of me she's
asking the questions that you want to
know this is going to be a lot easier
than me just writing because i don't
know what you guys want to know
so uh it just it dragged me a little bit
this week it really between that on
tuesday the live podcast on thursday and
the show on thursday in san diego on the
drive and the [ __ ] cookie and
everything yeah it really killed me by
saturday i was wiped out i didn't know
why i was so sorry well you're pretty
open with the podcast every week i'm
open with the podcast but this is
remembering those years
is a [ __ ] nightmare it's a [ __ ]
nightmare because it takes me there some
nights i have to go there in my heart
and it's feel the desperation you know
friday night i stayed home
and i was just about ready to go to bed
nine o'clock hustle and floor was coming
up
and i watched the beginning of it and
hustling flows about a black guy
that has pimps
that has hookers a white chick and two
black chicks and they're all stars today
i guess in their own way i mean this
movie was great it was it starts off a
little slow i don't know how many years
old it is now 10 years old or whatever
it starts off a little slow but it gets
uh
it picks up it picks up in the story and
they start writing and every character
you'll see in this movie you've seen
before including ludicrous
and i don't know what happens i don't
want to spoil it for you but there's a
part in the movie when i was watching it
the other day and
and they're sitting there and they're
waiting for a client a trick
and he's riding reps
the pimp
is riding wraps in his car there's no
air conditioner
and the hooker is a young pretty girl
with no confidence zero confidence
but she looks over at him and she goes
hey
um
dee
i wish i could do something
just like that she goes no she goes i
wish i was good at
something you know
i wish i could do something one of those
sentences and it's it just destroyed my
insides because again like watching the
thief a couple weeks ago and seeing what
i wanted the other part of it was that
that was me
i always felt i was a thief because i
couldn't do anything
okay and i think that's a horrible way
to think i know there's a lot of people
that walk around thinking that they
can't do something at that age
it's horrible it's [ __ ] horrible it
really is horrible you know
and uh even that
even thinking that thought that i
thought that way
took a little wind out of my sails
because i can't believe why i thought
that way boy was i confused but if i was
confused
imagine how many other people are
confused thinking that they can't do
nothing that they have to settle for a
shitty [ __ ] job or settle for
something they don't want to do in life
it's so [ __ ] weird so
if you get a chance to watch hustle and
flow but if you feel that way sometimes
you have [ __ ] options
because that's what writing that book
reminds me that's what people are going
to see that they write that book
i never ever want to be a [ __ ]
celebrity i still consider myself a
celebrity that's a stupid [ __ ] word
you know and i'm not a movie star and
i'm just a dirty [ __ ] comic
and i sit down with another [ __ ]
dirty jew twice a week and we talk [ __ ]
okay
but we talk the truth and we talk what's
in our heart and we talk about the
things that we do and how it affects us
this podcast is about [ __ ] lee and
his growth this podcast is about making
somebody's day but this podcast is also
about thinking
that we can't do something and i don't
want you to think that way no more [ __ ]
all that [ __ ] you can do whatever the
[ __ ] you want it's monday [ __ ]
plain and simple that's why we ate the
edible that's why we smoked the vaper
pens and that's why we're gonna leave
you with a smile on our face i think i
can tell you what was so funny to me
well tell me now
you're doing the escape pod take out and
you're like i love to i love calling
jeremy i love talking to jamie on the
phone he always has answers for me she's
like quick line i love i love i love
talking to jeremy
why call a customer service guy if you
don't have [ __ ] answers lee you know
what i'm saying i just imagine like
answers about nothing it's like yeah
answers yeah we gotta answer and then if
you're asking about the mcdonald's
cheeseburger what's the 88 cents yeah
why why call somebody ain't got no
[ __ ] answers you know what i'm saying
have a great [ __ ] week it's monday
june 2nd like i said you could do the
[ __ ] don't ever think you can't do it
dawg i thought the same [ __ ] way my
feelings was watching that movie so
get up there grab your [ __ ] balls
take the little syringe whatever you
what's that little sponge wash your
[ __ ] it's going to be a good day it's
going to be a great day oh the one with
charlie's i think i mean i think
whatever even if you just get the
[ __ ] towel and you don't have one
wipe charlie's wash that ass or get the
barnacles it's gonna be a good day trust
me it started off in doubt but it's
gonna be a good day stay black i wanna
thank all our sponsors on it dollar
shave club hulu plus escape pod tank
thank you for a beautiful monday have a
great day see you wednesday we haven't
decided on what time it will not be a
morning one have a [ __ ] great day
stay black a little something for my
people from new jersey 10th avenue
freeze out stay black now that the
show's over don't forget to sign up for
your free trial hulu plus hulu plus lets
you binge on thousands of hit shows
anytime anywhere on your tv pc
smartphone or tablet support this
podcast and an extended free trial of
hulu plus when you go to huluplus.com
joey or go to joeydiaz.net and click on
the hulu plus banner and don't forget to
sign up for dollarshaveclub.com get high
quality razors sent to your door every
month for a fraction of what you pay at
retail now go to dollarshaveclub.com
forward slash church or just go to
joeydias.net and click on the dollar
share club